et tous les moyens pour imposer leur
vérité
[Musique]
ils exigent notamment la justice
climatique partout dans le monde des
manifestants se sont rassemblés ce
samedi pour réclamer des mesures
d'urgence à paris ou encore un glasgow
en écosse épicentre de cette journée de
mobilisation alors que se poursuit la
coop 26
blabla de la vraie action climatique
maintenant c'est ce qu'ont scandé les
protestataires
[Musique]
un nouveau record de contamination en
russie malgré la semaine jamais plus de
41000 330 nouveaux cas de grippe ont été
enregistrés en 24 heures à l'épidémie ne
faiblit pas une propagation du
coronavirus
édité par le faible taux de vaccination
de la population seules 33 bien gueuler
pour cent des russes se comptent à ce
jour totalement immunisés
[Musique]
les résultats préliminaires des
législatives d'octobre continuent de se
mobiliser en irak des centaines de
partisans pro et rend compte à nouveau
manifesté dans la journée ils dénoncent
une fraude massive
mobilisation alors que les bars qui
poursuivent leurs tractations en vue de
former des coalitions parlementaire
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
un samedi de rassemblement et d'action
pour le climat en plaine comme 26 des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants se
sont donc rassemblés un peu partout dans
le monde pour alerter face à l'urgence
climatique
parmi leurs revendications la justice
sydney londres mexico paris glasgow plus
de vingt manifestations étaient
organisées aujourd'hui tour d'horizon
allez petit bogeys nord
de paris à sydney en passant par londres
plus de 200 actions aujourd'hui pour
alerter sur l'urgence climatique
épicentre de ces mobilisations glasgow
où la manifestation a attiré les foules
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes se sont rassemblées et ont
défilé dans les rues tout près du centre
de congrès où se tient actuellement la
coque 26 mme ce ne sont pas seulement
les jeunes ce sont les syndicalistes ce
sont les gens qui travaillent autour de
la pauvreté ce sont les écologistes et
les organisations confessionnelles tous
s'unissent et 10 nous sommes dans un
moment de crise énorme c'est une crise
multiple mais elle a les mêmes racines
c'est une économie brisée c'est une
économie truqués et cela nous met tous
au bord de la catastrophe
nous avons les solutions nous pouvons
réparer à la fois la planète et nous
pouvons lutter contre les inégalités
mondiales et la pauvreté ce qui nous
manque c'est la volonté politique de nos
dirigeants à paris le rassemblement
s'est déroulé sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville ils étaient quelques centaines à
donner de la voix pour le climat mais
surtout contre les dirigeants mondiaux
particulièrement visé par les
protestataires
emmanuel macron boris johnson joe biden
chasing ping ou encore jacques herbaut
lso naro-1 riz glasgow mais aussi sydney
là bas certains manifestants se sont
déguisés en tas de charbon d'autres ont
pris l'alluré du premier ministre
australien scott morrison défenseur de
l'industrie minière c'est terrifiant je
veux dire vous entendez dans 50 ans et
30 ans et 100 ans
c'est le rhin jeudi mais vous savez vous
pouvez voir les effets qui se produisent
maintenant
quand vous parlez aux anciens il n'y
avait pas de cyclones chaque année dans
les îles du pacifique et maintenant
chaque année vous voyez un cyclone passé
et faire des ravages sur nos îles j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu une
imposture les conférences de ce genre
font souvent des promesses vides
morrison a opté pour l'objectif zéro
émission d'ici à 2050 ce n'est qu'une
astuce pour le long terme et cela n'a
rien à voir avec la transition que nous
devons opérer dès maintenant des message
clair envoyé aux dirigeants mondiaux en
plaine comme 26 après une semaine de
discussions de nouveaux engagements ont
été annoncées notamment par le brésil
l'argentine ou encore l'inde les
négociations doivent se poursuivre
jusqu'au 12 novembre
et les manifestants réclament des
actions concrètes immédiates comme
marine calme est présidente de
l'association wild & gold ce qui est
réclamé aujourd'hui par l'ensemble des
militants écologistes mais aussi tout
simplement des citoyens et des jeunes
c'est tout simplement de sortir du bla
bla bla et de rentrer dans les actions
concrètes pas en 2050 parce qu'en 2050
il sera trop tard mais dans les
prochaines années immédiatement pour
pouvoir agir que ce soit sur le charbon
la déforestation et l ensemble des
énergies fossiles dont il faut sortir
aujourd'hui ce sont des actions qui
doivent être mises en place
immédiatement et on ne peut pas se
laisser un délai de 30 40 ou 50 ans pour
agir sinon c'est trop tard
à l'épidémie de covin repart en france
on cause la baisse des températures une
vaccination qui plafonne et le
relâchement aussi des gestes-barrières
emmanuel macron prendra la parole mardi
soir et cet après midi le premier
ministre jean castex a annoncé
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
files d'attentes des remontées
mécaniques des stations de ski ainsi que
celle du pass annie terre si le taux
d'incidence national dépasse les 200 cas
pour 100000 habitants pas sanitaire
prolongé jusqu'à l'été ch après
validation par le parlement mesure qui a
une fois de plus fait descendre dans les
rues de paris ses opposants emmenés par
le leader du parti des patriotes florian
philippot or rien n'est jamais foutu et
des peuples qui se sont libérés après
des années de persévérance et il était
tout le temps tout le temps tout temps
là chaque semaine macron va parler mardi
soir je pense que s'il parle c'est qu'il
se sent que le doute est en train de
s'immiscer dans les esprits au contraire
les ça n'est pas ça ne passe plus comme
une lettre à la poste ne l'avait vu au
parlement on aimerait bien qu'ils aient
un peu de courage qui respecte tout
simplement les les valeurs de notre pays
c'est à dire la non discrimination qui
doit être quand même un principe absolu
de de constitution mais a priori ça gêne
pas beaucoup de politiques je suis là
parce que si je n'étais pas là ça veut
dire que tout le monde abandonne et ça
veut dire que on accepte l'inacceptable
on accepte d'être des qr codes on
accepte ça effectivement que le notre
vie basique c'est à dire pouvoir prendre
un café en terrasse
soit soumis à une liberté qui est quand
même fondamentale celle de se faire
vacciner ou pas et la gestion de la
crise sanitaire n'en finit pas
d'interroger le regard de notre
éditorialiste michel fize les français
éprouvent une grande lassitude
ils en ont assez tout ceci ils
comprennent pas très bien pourquoi il ya
une interdiction à tel endroit et pas à
tel autre pourquoi on peut faire ceci et
pas faire cela selon les lieux selon les
les activités voilà donc yaya il ya une
grande confusion et puis encore une fois
par rapport aux chiffres ont peu comme
avoir des doutes on vous annonce 2000
3000 cas de contamination et puis 72
heures après vous avez dix mille cas
voilà alors bon sens pas une
manipulation on pourrait quand même se
demander comment sont bâtis ces chiffres
en payer incontestablement des
maladresses de communication on voit
bien notamment par rapport à la mesure
de la troisième dose qui se profile
c'est que bon on ne sait pas si ce sera
obligatoire ou quasi obligatoire est ce
que ce sera uniquement pour les
personnes fragiles ou les personnes de
plus de 65 ans est ce qu'on va élargir
élargir ou pas voilà donc c'est vrai que
les messages ne sont pas ne sont pas
simples donc cette cette inquiétude en
et en est le résultat une situation
compliquée dans les hôpitaux free puiser
par des mois de crise sanitaire et des
conditions de travail qu'ils jugent à
dégradé un nombre élevé de soignants
jette l'épongé résultats en lice sur 5
en moyenne et fermés faute de personnel
illustration à l'hôpital de laval c'est
un reportage de renault parc est
immédiat
une situation qui paraît presque
irréelle la nuit du 4 au 5 comme celle
du 1er au 2 novembre les portes des
urgences de l'hôpital de laval sont
restées closes pour cette représentante
du personnel aide soignante dans le
service concerné
la cause est toujours la même quand un
urgentiste pendant sa garde à 8h30 le
matin il arrive parfois avec 15 patients
qui sont présents dans le couloir des
urgences depuis la veille donc soit 12 à
24 heures pour certains patients qui
reste sur des brancards ou sur des lits
qui sont sur des brancards transformer
en lit par manque de lits dans les
services et donc de glee dans les
services par manque d'effectifs médicaux
au total une centaine de personnels aux
urgences pour une centaine de passages
par jour
insuffisant d'après la chef du service
dans une situation catastrophique au
niveau des effectifs médicaux on est
cinq équivalents temps plein pour une
cible entre 16 et 18 donc on peut pas
faire fonctionner le planning
correctement donc on a été obligé pour
la première fois dans l'histoire des
urgences de laval de fermer la nuit la
nuit du 1er au 2 et puis la nuit qui
vient de se finir on affirmer aussi pour
elle trois points sont à revoir le flux
d'amont qui correspond à l'arrivée des
patients aux urgences les déserts
médicaux contraignent les malades à se
rendre aux urgences faute de médecins et
engorgent les services il faudrait selon
elle que les patients puissent être
prise en charge avant les urgences
également en cause l'environnement au
travail le personnel médical exercent
souvent dans des conditions difficiles
et beaucoup partent ou abandonnent leurs
activités enfin troisième point crucial
le flux d'aval il faudrait d'après les
professionnels de santé plus de lits
pour hospitaliser correctement les
patients la mise en place de la réserve
sanitaire ne compense pas le manque de
médecins et pour l'association de
citoyens contre les déserts médicaux
cette situation n'est pas un hasard
le constat c'est que déjà
on a non médecins qui sont actuellement
en activité qui vont arriver à la
retraite et pour une bonne partie qui
sont bons alors prête qu'à l'heure
actuelle si ma mémoire est bonne il doit
y avoir à peu près quatre à cinq mille
citoyens mayennais enfin notamment
lavallois qui n'ont plus de médecins
traitants faut savoir ce qu'on veut où
on veut sauver la populace soigner la
population ou alors on s'en fout
contactée par téléphone la direction de
l'hôpital a préféré ne pas répondre à
nos sollicitations
évoquant notamment son devoir de réserve
cette nuit si les urgences seront à
nouveau fermées
et la reprise de l'épidémie concerne
toute l'europe les pays bas viennent
ainsi d'enregistrer un nombre quasi
records de nouveaux cas de contamination
et plus de 12 milles en 24 heures le
plus élevé depuis le début de l'année à
les autorités se font donc décidé de
serrer la vis depuis ce matin retour du
port obligatoire du masque dans les
lieux fermés de la distanciation social
obligations aussi de présenter le
passage du ter dont les musées ou les
terrasses de restaurants l'exécutif
conseille également de privilégier le
télétravail est d'éviter les transports
aux heures de pointe alors comment
expliquer cette situation sanitaire
alors que 84 % de la population est
vaccinée dans le pays nous avons posé la
question à ma vie fallières anesthésiste
à l'hôpital de dornach
c'est une bande et mines épidémie de non
vaccinés s'il n'y avait que les gens
vaccinés qui sont en échappement à cause
de lignite et c'est sans le savait on
pourrait gérer on est dans les problèmes
à cause des innovact signer pour des
raisons religieuses pour des raisons de
complotisme nous de suivre des décidé
complètement folle donc pas les
restrictions arrivé de bien falloir que
les gens se fassent vacciner on n'a pas
tellement le choix il faut relativiser
par rapport à l'année dernière on avait
un autre variante était moins contagieux
on a variant delta qui se promènent qui
se propage à toute vitesse donc quand on
regarde les chiffres c'est pas si
alarmante ça qu'on regarde les chiffres
simplement brut il faut penser qu'on ne
peut plus permettre d'annuler de décaler
des soins donc tous les lits qui sont
occupés on en a besoin pour autre chose
les lits sont peu extensif en étant 2021
on a des durées de séjour qui sont
extrêmement courte 1 de quatre jours à
peu près en hospitalisation
aux pays bas on a plus haut tandis
qu'avant on a plus de personnel comme
avant on est plutôt confronté à une
réduction de livres dans le but d'une
efficacité et d'un meilleur hôte comme
des patients et on a pu la place pour
tous ces gens non vaccinés qui lui dénie
c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup moins qu'il
ya un an mais il ya un an on annulait
tous les programmes là on peut plus se
permettre un record de contamination
également en russie malgré la semaine
chômé la situation sanitaire se dégrade
on fait le point avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine caron
nouveau record pour la russie sur le
front du coc vide celui du nombre de
nouveaux cas quotidiens qui s'élève ce
samedi à 41 1335 le nombre de décès ces
dernières 24 heures reste lui aussi un
niveau très élevé 1188 décès recensés
l'église orthodoxe qui occupe une place
importante dans la vie sociale de
nombreux russes s'est également exprimé
sur la situation sanitaire l'institution
préconise un confinement strict avec la
généralisation du recours aux qr code
nous y arriverons tôt ou tard et le plus
tôt sera le mieux parce que chaque jour
nous perdons un millier de personnes
c'est comme si nous perdions chaque jour
un régiment pendant la guerre vu le taux
de mortalité je pense que l'on peut
parler de catastrophe nationale
le ministre russe de la santé est
actuellement en déplacement en province
afin de se rendre compte lui même de la
situation sur place il en a profité pour
annoncer l'envoi de nouveaux stocks de
vaccins dans les régions et a dit
s'inquiéter de l'augmentation de
l'incidence du coc u19 sur les enfants
il faut souligner qu'il est très
important de protéger les tout jeunes
enfants parce que l'expertisé d'un
nouveau médicament est actuellement en
cours elle est même déjà terminé en fait
on espère qu'il sera disponible sous peu
tous ces vaccins sont produits sur la
base du sérum spoutnik qui a déjà fait
ses preuves quant à sa sûreté et son
efficacité face à une population
toujours aussi réticents à se faire
vacciner les autorités russes cherchent
comme elles peuvent à casser l'élan de
cette quatrième vague particulièrement
meurtrière elle espère que la semaine
chaumet qui s'achève ce dimanche y
contribuera
nouvelle manifestation après des
affrontements à bagdad une personne
serait morte et une centaine de
personnes blessées lors de heurts entre
les forces de sécurité et des partisans
chiite qui protestaient contre les
résultats des élections législatives la
branche politique de la coalition h al
chabi a perdu de nombreux sièges à
l'issue du vote et dénonce une fraude
massive les résultats définitifs du
scrutin devraient être publiés d'ici
quelques semaines et mini google
françois des lambert
nouvelle mobilisation de partisans pro
iran dans la capitale ils sont des
centaines à s'être retrouvés pour
protester contre les résultats des
législatives le rassemblement s'est
déroulé dans le calme pourtant ce samedi
matin les voitures calcinées et les
nombreux débris était là pour témoigner
des violences qui ont émaillé la nuit
dernière dans la capitale irakienne des
violences qui ont fait un mort hier
après midi des centaines de
protestataires chiites se sont retrouvés
près de la zone verte à bagdad la partie
ultra protégé de la ville où se trouvent
de nombreux ministères et ambassades
depuis deux semaines les militants du
hashtag j'habite dénonce les résultats
préliminaires des législatives
une coalition composée de factions pro
iranienne regroupant d'anciens
paramilitaires intégré par la suite aux
forces régulières irakiennes
après avoir manifesté dans le calme le
rassemblement a sombré dans le chaos au
cours de la nuit selon certaines sources
proches de ces groupes la police
irakienne a tiré à balles réelles sur
les manifestants
une version non confirmée par le
ministère de la santé qui assure qu
aucun décès n'est à déplorer ces
violences témoignent de la situation
toujours très tendue dans le pays alors
que les résultats définitifs des
législatives ne sont toujours pas connus
selon les premières estimations
un autre courant chiite celui dirigé par
l'influent leader moktada sadr a
remporté le scrutin il aurait obtenu
plus de 70 sièges sur les 329 que compte
le parlement les malgré sa déroute le
hashtag chaabi devrait rester une force
politique importante grâce à de
nombreuses alliances des événements qui
font craindre un possible conflit armé
dans ce contexte toujours incertain et
face au risque d'embrasement la mission
de l'eau nu en irak a déploré l'
escalade de la violence et appelé toutes
les parties à faire preuve du maximum de
retenue
et ce drame en sierra leone au moins 98
personnes sont mortes et 92 blessés dans
l'explosion d'un camion-citerne cela
s'est passé ce vendredi soir dans la
capitale la population est sous le choc
médias ce qui fit
près de 100 morts et des dizaines de
personnes gravement brûlées c'est le
bilan du drame survenu ce vendredi soir
dans la capitale du sierra leone
freetown à l'origine un accident a
provoqué l'explosion d'un camion citerne
les flammes se sont ensuite propagées
dans le quartier est piégé des dizaines
d'habitants le président se dit
bouleversé par cet événement dramatique
profondément troublé par les incendies
tragique et les horribles pertes de vies
humaines dans la région de wellington
pmb mes sincères condoléances aux
familles qui ont perdu des êtres chers
et à ceux qui en ont été mutilés mon
gouvernement fera tout pour soutenir les
familles touchées d'après le
gouvernement des dizaines de personnes
sont prises en charge à l'hôpital
certaines présenterait de graves
brûlures selon des sources de la fp le
vice président s'est rendu ce samedi sur
place pour déplorer une catastrophe
nationale devant la foule et a promis
une assistance médicale gratuite pour
les blessés
il s'agit d'une catastrophe nationale au
nom du président du gouvernement et de
l'ensemble du peuple sierra leone et
nous compatissons avec les personnes
touchées par cette catastrophe qui ont
perdu la vie le gouvernement est au fait
de la situation et nous nous efforcerons
de leur donner le meilleur traitement
médical possible dans les hôpitaux 34
emergency choi tram échos note
de son côté la mère de freetown a réagi
sur les réseaux sociaux en se disant
profondément attristé
je suis profondément attristé
d'apprendre qu'une explosion s'est
produite le long de bébour et road à
wellington après qu'un camion citerne
transportant du carburant est entré en
collision avec un autre camion je
présente mes condoléances aux familles
aux proches des victimes de l'explosion
que les âmes des défunts reposant
parfaite paix ce samedi matin les
secouristes étaient encore à la
recherche de corps calcinés sur les
lieux du drame de nombreux habitants
sont également présents à la recherche
de leurs proches
états unis arabie saoudite norvège suède
ou encore danemark appellent leurs
ressortissants à quitter l'ethiopie
washington ordonne même le départ de ces
diplomates non essentiels à les combats
ont redoublé cette semaine dans le nord
du pays entre forces gouvernementales et
rebelles du front de libération du
peuple du tigré ces derniers menacent de
marcher sur la capitale aux côtés des
combattants de l'armée de libération
oromo groupe armé avec lequel laïque se
sont alliés depuis août l'onu appelle un
cessez-le-feu les précisions de farah
may cry
une alliance qui pourrait faciliter une
offensive des insurgés vers la capitale
éthiopienne ce vendredi le front de
libération du peuple du tigré et l'armée
de libération oromo se sont unis à cet
autre groupe indépendantiste provenant
de différentes régions du pays
par le front uni des forces fédéralistes
et confédéraliste éthiopienne le 5
novembre 2021
nous les forces fédéralistes et
confédéraliste d'ethiopie avons le
plaisir d'annoncer la création d'un
front le front uni des forces
fédéralistes et confédéraliste
éthiopienne
l'objectif de cette union
destitué le gouvernement en place menée
par le premier ministre habib ahmed une
menace sérieuse pourtant balayé d'un
revers de la main par les autorités
gouvernementales
elles démentent une quelconque avancée
des rebelles dans le pays ce conflit ne
doit en aucun cas être traité comme un
engagement entre égaux car le
gouvernement fédéral ait mandaté comme
je le disais par la constitution pour
préserver la paix et la sécurité dans le
pays également je tenais donc à
souligner cet aspect car beaucoup de ces
appels ont tendance à ne pas dénoncer
suffisamment un groupe armé insurgés et
un groupe ou une entité qui a été
désignée comme une organisation
terroriste conformément au processus
constitutionnel et aux lois du pays
depuis quelques semaines le nord du pays
est le théâtre de violents affrontements
entre l'armée gouvernementale et les
rebelles tigréens les indépendantistes
ont récupéré mais quelle est la capitale
de la région avant d'étendre leur
contrôle région d'amhara et d'afar une
perte de terrain considérable pour les
autorités fédérales qui nie ses échecs
le premier ministre éthiopien a décrété
l'état d'urgence sur l'ensemble du
territoire avant d'appeler la population
à s'organiser et à prendre les armes
pour lutter contre l'avancée des
rebelles vers la capitale une sortie
condamnée par les nations unies
les membres du conseil de sécurité ont
exprimé leur profonde inquiétude au
sujet de l'extension et de
l'intensification des affrontements
militaires dans le nord de l'ethiopie
les membres du conseil de sécurité se
sont en outre déclaré gravement
préoccupé par les répercussions du
conflit sur la situation humanitaire en
ethiopie ainsi que sur la stabilité du
pays et de toute la région des conflits
depuis le début du conflit la situation
humanitaire ne cesse de s'aggraver dans
le pays aux tigres et 400000 personnes
connaissent la famille pendant qu en
afar et en a marre à ce sont un million
700 mille éthiopiens qui sont confrontés
à une pénurie de nourriture
d'après l'onu
joe biden salue l'avancée colossal de
ses projets de réformes que le congrès
validé hier son plan d'investissement
dans les infrastructures 1200 milliards
de dollars pour moderniser les routes et
ponts vétusté rattraper aussi les
retards dans l'internet à haut débit
cette loi qu'il la promulgue aura
bientôt c'est ce qu'il a annoncé reste
encore au président américain à
surmonter les divisions démocrates pour
faire voter le grand volet social
écologique de ces réformes sébastien
abat une victoire du camp démocrate
n'aurait pas été de trop pour joe biden
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi le
congrès a reporté un vote cher au
président américain qui prévoyait une
refonte de la couverture maladie d'une
part et des investissements pour réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'autre part une enveloppe colossale de
1800 milliards de dollars était prévu
pour mettre en oeuvre ce projet un
nouveau vote est attendu à la fin du
mois la présidente démocrate du congrès
a rappelé la nécessité d'agir vite
nous avons attendu un certain temps nous
avions espéré l'adopter plus tôt mais
nous ne pouvons pas attendre trop
longtemps pour la législation je crois
qu'un grand nombre de membres du caucus
progressiste voteront pour le projet de
loi
si le temps presse pour joe biden c'est
parce que le camp démocrate majoritaire
au congrès se fragilise en plus de
conflits internes
le retour de la dir giny sous pavillon
républicains après l'élection décisive
d'un nouveau gouverneur cette semaine a
eu l'effet d'une bombe pour les fidèles
du président malgré cette défaite une
lueur d'espoir pour joe biden son autre
projet phare le plan infrastructures
destinées à moderniser le pays a lui été
adopté
d'un montant faramineux ce plan
constitue l'un des plus ambitieux de
l'histoire moderne du pays il ne manque
plus que la signature du président pour
mettre la machine en route
ce soir nous avons fait un pas en avant
monumentale en tant que nation la
chambre des représentants des états unis
a adopté le plan d'investissement
infrastructure un projet de loi dit
partisan unique en son genre qui créera
des millions d'emplois transformera la
crise climatique en opportunités et nous
mettra sur la bonne voie pour gagner la
compétition économique du 21ème siècle
une victoire en demi teinte pour le
président américain alors que se
profilent à l'horizon les élections de
mi mandat une étape historiquement
difficile à passer pour le camp
démocrate
et le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images un
scrutin à valeur de test 18 mois avant
la présidentielle nigériane l'état
d'anambra dans le sud-est du pays voter
aujourd'hui pour élire un nouveau
gouverneur et plus de 30 mille policiers
ont été déployés pour sécuriser
l'élection après une série d'attaqués
attribuées au mouvement indépendantiste
pour les peuples indigènes du biafra qui
réclament en état indépendant
un incendie a tué au moins onze malades
du cornât virus dans un hôpital de
l'ouest de l'inde le feu s'est déclenché
dans cette unité de soins intensifs qui
comprenait une vingtaine de patients
les circonstances du drame restent
floues une enquête a été ouverte sous
financer le système de santé public
indien a atteint un point critique avec
la forte vague de covin d'avril mais
plusieurs hôpitaux ont déjà dû faire
face à des incendies de ce genre
en allemagne un homme a attaqué au
couteau des passagers d'un train à
grande vitesse reliant regensburg à
nürnberg en bavière trois personnes ont
été grièvement blessées l'auteur présumé
a été interpellé on ignore ses
motivations mais selon plusieurs médias
allemands il s'agirait d'un syrien qui
pourraient souffrir de troubles
psychiatriques les autorités rejettent
pour l'heure la piste terroriste
et c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à total
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
kicked off est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont désintéresserait en lieu
et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des candides n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pic il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas un
oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
d'avoir amitié
[Musique]
pour
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé
il était nulle part parce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de fine stratégie peut porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis honnête chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine un invité exceptionnel vive
koppens bonjour bonjour je pense que
tout le monde vous connaît vous êtes
paléontologues c'est votre métier c'est
votre passion
vous êtes sans doute le plus célèbre
paléontologue de la planète on va le
voir je crois vous avez fait une
quarantaine de livres qui sont vendus
dans le monde entier qui raconte
finalement l'avis des premiers hommes
vous donner des clés pour comprendre
d'où on vient
c'est ça votre motivation c'est sale le
but de la paléontologie